bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
we're here trying to help you understand
Islam and Muslims now we're gonna be
talking about the most important topic
in Islam Islam simply simply it's very
simple means to surrender your will to
the will of the creator that means
you're gonna do what the Creator wants
you to do now this topic is something
that all the messengers of God talked
about they delivered this same simple
message it's not complicated your young
son and young daughter can understand
this if your non-muslim do not turn the
channel if you've got your non-muslim
friend or even for the Muslims that
might have some confusion about this
they're talking about everything under
the Sun except this most important
factor God Almighty is the most merciful
and loving and if you get this wrong and
you take a wrong turn here and you put a
partner next to the one who created you
this can be something that can put you
in a place that is very hot but if you
get it right which we want you to get it
right
this can land you in a place of eternal
bliss and happiness so when we come back
we're going to be discussing tawheed
pure monotheism like nothing or anything
else that you've ever heard pure
monotheism when we come back here on the
Deen show with my brother and your
brother come out automatically right
so I'm making peace be unto you - Allah
how are you doing brother
100% back on the Deen show happy to have
you here always a pleasure thank you and
may Allah the Creator that happens in
earth reward you for taking your time to
be with us there's so many people that
are out there they're wanting to know
the truth and we're trying to deliver it
in a simple way so everyone can
understand and this is the most
important topic that food Arabic we Sato
heed what does this mean so he refers to
the oneness of allah subhanho taught
when you say a loss on dollar what is
this for me it means allah you know the
most exalted basically but Allah of
course is God in Arabic yeah but you see
the topic of to hate it means Allah is
one right yeah and most people when they
hear that it like okay well that's easy
and I don't need to hear about this
anymore and even some Muslims now when
you talk about the headache so he'd
again I think we're tired of this topic
yeah but you can't ever get tired of the
topic it's the most important one to get
this wrong you have problems say the
least
fail the test okay but let's look at it
this way uh-huh you know one of the
things that proved the importance of
tohave is that on every single page of
the Quran there is a mention of Tawhid
either direct or indirect every single
page this is the verbatim word of a lot
of God Almighty and the Quran it's on
every single every single page so then
the Muslims who read the Quran why don't
they sort of hit again to hit again
because it's that important Ya Allah put
it on every page like what if the whole
page is talking about an incident
between Moosa and Pharaoh and firown'
for example
how that is all about though hey that
the whole conflict started because it Oh
hate yeah so every single page of the
Quran either directly or indirectly is
mentioning to hate you know even the
name Allah is to hate in it so it's not
for a believing man or woman to say well
we woke retired with the subject of -
hey it's the most important topic yeah
that's one by every page of the whole
done having it
the other thing Allah judges is no for
an woman tsunami no public I mean Rasul
Allah no hay la la la Hilda Anna faboo
doin we have not sent a prophet before
you except that we revealed to him that
there is no God worthy of worship except
me so worship me so every prophet got
the message of Toki no prophet came
without this message that's the number
one name a few of them for example even
if you look at it biblical otherwise but
you look look at all the prophets look
at Moses musa alehsalaam he brought
tawheed Ibrahim brought though he'd
David Solomon Suleiman lot all of them
mentioned talked even Jesus of course
that people claim that he's the third
God had even he spoke of Torah and the
majority I mean of humanity just by
coincidence that when you mentioned
these names mos'ly Abraham Noah I mean
even people that are so-called like
atheists they know these names
absolutely know these people these
messengers I'll tell you something
interesting
Yeah right they're the scholars that
Muslim scholars believe that there's no
such thing as a pure a theist and I also
believe this very strong yeah that there
is no human being on the face of the
planet who is 100% atheist there is no
such thing yeah even even the people who
absolutely are adamant that they're
atheist deep deep down sometimes they
can't dig that deep down yeah they
believe there is a God yeah it's not
true you you just deny something that's
within your very nature huh
and the proof they use you know that is
a verse in sort of a number the ant
where Allah says talking about Pharaon
who claim to be God Pharaoh boiled
people alive because they believed in
Allah he said there is no god but me he
was I mean he boiled people alive so he
must really not believe there's another
girl that was a king yeah back at the
time of Moses Moses okay so if he boiled
people alive he must really be sure
there is no God right but then Allah
says really powerful verse
well jihad will be wasted Anna
for so we'll mawa halwa that they denied
it but they were certain of it in
internally they were certain of the
existence of Allah if this guy is
boiling people alive he's so sure
there's no God and Allah says he's
certain that there is that means
everybody else for sure I mean no one as
bad as he is
no one went that far yeah so that means
everybody in deep down they believe that
there is a god yeah and as much as they
deny it well just this is just on a side
note why do you think just they deny it
why they cover it up well because a lot
of times people come from a religion
where the the background is that the
explanations are not adequate and so
they think that well this doesn't make
sense and the concept of God in this
religion doesn't make sense there is no
God people made this up yeah those
people haven't looked at it in Islam and
they haven't read the Quran that's we're
going to learn now and this show God
willing because obviously when you start
saying that God was a man that he had a
son that he was a monkey or an elephant
or rat these kind of things that there's
weird things out there you start to
associate an intelligent person who's
using his head that this ain't right so
they put all religions in the same
bucket or even a god that would
physically come down earth wrestle with
men not even be able to out wrestle them
and do kind of strange things that not
very appealing to some people so it
turned them off from the whole idea of
God but the problem is they need to look
at it everywhere look at the concept in
Islam as well don't put all the
religions under one umbrella and say all
of them don't have a good concept so
they got we got their attention say what
okay now what do you have to offer
what's this toe he'd you're talking
about
well basically talk is like the simple
message that we were saying and it's
linked to your eternal salvation to
believe in Allah and to only worship Him
alone not to associate any living being
or tree or rock or anything with him and
this is a problem that we have with all
the majority of religions or all just
about all religions and within Islam
itself we have Muslims now who instead
of directing all of their worship 100%
of it to Allah they directed a portion
of it or a part of it to something
besides Allah hoping that this will link
them to Allah bring them closer to
whatever it is but it still is still
wrong it still not to hate because in a
hadith authentic hadith Allah subhana
Allah says I am another shortcut on his
shirt he says
in need of partners in the least whoever
worships me and something else with me I
will direct all his worship to that
other item that means you don't set up
no partner no Co eco with God it's only
got only the Creator only Allah alone
when we come back we'll give some
examples on a TV show
all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message with the same initial submission
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the pulpit on Sunday
morning and preach a sermon that I knew
was at variance with the actual taproot
of Christianity back here in a Deen show
okay so the messengers came with that
same message worship God submit to God
alone now you have people developing all
these different philosophies theologies
and they are going away from the simple
message how did this occur all right
well historically it would start off it
would actually start off one of there
are a number of things okay that lead to
something being worshipped besides Allah
one of them is over praising someone or
something and this for this reason is
very interesting the Arabs came to the
prophet sallallaahu Prophet Muhammad SAW
said Allah and they told him they
praised him they said you are our best
and the son of our best you are saying
it and the son of our best so he stopped
them he said do not over praise me as
the Christians over praise the son of
Mary now in another day he said I am the
best but when they came and told him you
were the best he stopped them why he was
cutting off the avenue to being over
praised because he knew that
overpraising is one of the avenues that
leads you to becoming worship let's take
the example of the people of Noah the
Prophet Noah his people there were some
righteous men you know in the area and
people love these righteous men so much
and they start to over praise them and
and you know mention them so well and
when these people died over the
generations and with all this praise and
stories and nonsense that started to
surround them they became gods it wasn't
anymore that this was a righteous man
who lived many years ago this was a god
and so what so uh yeah with the open
that sort of ever mentioned these were
all names of righteous men who became
idols in the end because people put
something to represent them you know
this righteous man used to stand and
pray here when he dies we put a rock
where he used to stand and then after a
while guess what some generations later
this rock is worship now instead of
that's a partner next to the Creator
exactly okay so now overpraising is one
of the average that lead to it even
idols and making statues and images is
one of the things that helps that
pronounce twice sure absolutely
okay and that's why in Islam to preserve
Islam we were not allowed to make idols
and images so that eventually people
might worship them King and so basically
the idea is that you know Allah Allah
created you and he's the only one who
gives you all the good that you have and
then you come up and take some some rock
or tree or stone and you start to
worship that how about a man or monkey
even worse I mean because you know it's
like you know someone does good to you
let's say someone you know by it pays
for your ticket like you know what
you've done you know I've brought I've
been brought all the way to Chicago you
guys have been so good and we're eating
out and all this stuff and imagine at
the end of all this trip
III go to some stranger in the street
you know thank you very much for
bringing me down here thanks for all the
good food and I appreciate it and I live
I die thank some stranger in the street
doesn't make any sense
Allah is the one who gives you
everything you have and then you go and
ingenuous lectin bow down to a piece of
rock yeah or to someone else or to his
messenger yeah who came to tell you the
worship him well what about some people
who say you know what these people are
more righteous than us they have a
better connection so we're trying to go
through them to get the God
and and the answer really bluntly is
that these people are none of your
business and Allah says that no Quran
but in a nicer way Allah says Allah
Allah la khawfun alayhim wala whom he
has an own yeah the only are these close
friends of allah meaning is righteous
man there is no fear upon them nor will
they become saddened the I doesn't
mention you there's no fear for them nor
will they be sad
so you rubbing on their shoes and trying
to worship them and and and kiss their
feet and stuff it has nothing to do with
you mm-hmm you know so so who do you
have to follow the Prophet SAW said
Allah
I know people argue to say well they're
righteous man we need to see what they
did yeah they become righteous man no
you don't you need to see what the
process of them did that'll take you to
write so so I'm so sinful now
someone who's done so much bad this
person is such a righteous person and
they compare it like you know what if
you want to go see the president you
don't and you can't just go directly to
them you have to go through the
secretary or you have to go to the
Attorney General
etc or know someone has connected this
is how I can get to my mission and and
that's actually an insult to Allah
because you know a tyrant or someone
who's not accessible to his people you
have to go through his secretaries and
go through his ministers to reach them
all right
but at the time of the first caliph Abu
Bakr did you have to go through anyone
was he accessible yes because it was a
very good leader right the Prophet SAW
said lamb was he accessible or did you
have to go through OMA he was accessible
why because he was a very good man and
very good leader
all the prophets like Jesus Moses April
associate we're all accessible to be the
poor man could walk straight up to Jesus
and ask him they didn't have to go
through and make an appointment now for
you know I'll see you in two weeks only
how it works with tyrants and games so
that's a bad analogy you're saying this
about Allah you got to go through
someone to get there so we got to fix
the question how big big time because
Allah says no hold on that if you call
me I'll answer yeah you know that I'm
close to you how about we go in the
confession box and people go behind the
screen and they confess their sins and
get a few Hail Marys and then they're
all good what about this and that's the
thing that's the beauty of Islam I don't
have to get in my car and drive and go
into the little box to tell somebody
anything you have a direct relationship
with Allah I mean it's really weird that
you have a direct relationship with
Allah and you got to go somewhere to a
tree to a box to a dad to a grave
whether it's a dead man Allah tell do
you have a direct link I so rational is
that's the easiest thing wouldn't be
yeah why do people fall into this you
think there's always a philosophy
there's always an explanation behind it
some and some went so extreme some
groups actually believe and Allah is far
removed from this that a part of Allah
emanates and comes into this human being
or this chef and that's why you can make
sujood and prostrate to him and it's not
a big deal because of a part of Allah is
in him things of that sort so the
nonsense can keep going on and on on the
truth is it's so simple
yeah there's only one God there's no
link you don't need intercession
intermediaries between you and him and
that's it it doesn't get easier than
that did Moses praise
Jesus or that Jesus pray through someone
or did the first man Adam the first man
Adam that's when we go back to the
original right did he go through anybody
or did any of the messengers what was
the way they did it well
obviously the way they did it was
basically it was a direct relationship
between you and Allah they prayed to
Allah directly and if you want to look
at it biblically it's very interesting
in the Old Testament how many times God
would warn not one threatened threatened
like Solomon and David and threatened
them if you ever take anything in
worship besides me I mean these are
actual threats I'll do this to you if
you do I'll do that to you I'll have
this happen to your women
I'll have that happened to really strong
threats don't you dare take anything in
worship besides me and this was a
consistent message in the Old Testament
and realistically it's consistent in the
New Testament as well but then suddenly
all of a sudden you have people adding
things to it and trying to say you know
that you worship others along with allah
or through them but there's no evidence
to any of them you made a beautiful
analogy something that you said if
someone had given you something and now
you didn't think that person you were
thinking someone else has nothing to do
with it can you give some more analogies
to bring it home so people can really
understand the simplicity of worshiping
God alone and something that is
unnatural and something that we
shouldn't be doing setting up or going
through anyone to get to God right well
I'm sure there was there was a nice
example of very logical as well and it
shows you the logic of tawheed where the
prophets had asked a man he tells him he
says how many gods do you worship he
says I worship six on earth and one in
the heavens yeah he said if the
situation gets really really bad who do
you call upon he said the one in heaven
he said then leave the six on earth and
just focus on the one in them yeah it
made perfect sense to them at it does it
make sense or not yeah it is so easy I
always though he'd will make much more
sense and why would I worship six but
when the going gets tough I worship the
one in the heaven that means he is the
one to go to yeah so leave the other six
then yeah
and that's the thing one actually one
Christian author he talks about he did a
study and he and he's saying that people
would love Jesus more than the meaning
looking at him as a god yeah loved him
more than the father why because they
see God the Father according to them as
someone who is so angry and can't
forgive until someone else has to die
for this sin then he'll start forgiving
and then the son is the sweet one who
came and offered up his life so that
they could be forgiven yeah so that's
why they loved him more and you hear
more talk about Jesus than you hear
about God why because he's the one who
came and died first he's the one who
loves us and so on and so forth so so
even when there is more than one God in
consequent theory you have people loving
one more than the other yeah so it's
it's an equation that just doesn't
balance all this love unconditional love
revering one the most is to the create
or I've created the Sun the Moon Jesus
Muhammad that's the guy yes tell us now
and we want to give some more examples
and because we're almost out of time
some modern day where some people will
sit and ask you know close their eyes
you see some kids calling on Santa too
if they're naughty or nice no they won't
get these presents so they're praying
like is it a prayer they're beseeching
him for these gifts and get me this and
I'll do this or some people will be
praying to Jesus and saying oh Jesus in
your name and this to the Father and
then some people also hand its head
they're praying through the Prophet
peace be upon him talk to us about this
well this is the problem is that
people's hearts are not attached to
Allah
they're attached to all kinds of other
things to attach to amulets that is
supposed to protect me and I mean and
that's what was forbidden bade all these
kinds of things mostly because they
replace Allah in your heart yeah I can
tell you stories of people who were
hanging onto these amulets and saying
you know it saved me a lot saved you
what you're talking about it's it's a
piece of paper that's folded up a little
bit so you're saying this thing saved
you instead of saying Allah saved me
you know people calling on on you know
relying on whatever if they're righteous
people or sorcerers
or profits or people who have passed
away why because there's no attachment
to a lot if people their hearts were
attached to Allah they wouldn't go
through these other avenues and shirk is
the biggest problem that we have in the
biggest problem that we have people
worshipping other than Allah or people
worshipping other things along with
Allah subhanAllah
so you don't ask Santa for these things
you ask the one who created you Allah
you don't pray through Jesus Moses
Muhammad you pray directly to the one
creator and ambulance that go around the
neck and around the arm and cetera we
don't need these lucky charms lucky
rabbit foot Lucky Penny what about that
actually I mean all of these they when
you look at the rabbit's foot and they
all have some kind of pagan belief you
know yeah the rabbits they thump the
ground sometimes with their feet like
that and so they both the people the
pagans believed that they were
communicating with gods that were under
the earth yeah and that's why the
rabbit's foot was lucky because that's
what it used to no it's not lucky for
the rabbit who's missing his foot
exactly huh not at all so and there's so
many other things you know that breaking
and mirrors but luck in the black cat
all of these when you trace their
history it goes back to some kind of
pagan belief or belief in more than one
God we're gonna continue talking about
pure monotheism tawheed and some of the
common things that people do that are
against is against things that the
messengers brought and the last final
motion prophet muhammad peace be
probably be back on the scene show say
to me why have you become a Muslim no I
give a very frivolous anse and I say I
want to be on the side of the angels
[ __ ] is a guy he's the number-one rap
artist in the world
he's sold over 60 million records were
60 million Steve Miller he was a young
guy where basically everything that
somebody who would think that life is
all about he had everything you can
imagine
I heard that people used to knock they
had a tree God and they used to knock on
this tree to wake them up so they can
ask and nowadays you'll see people like
when they say a phrase or a sentence say
Oh knock on wood right what do you think
about this you know sometimes people
will use these phrases and not realize
you know what it means but you know
knocking on wood it's related to that or
related to like again a pagan belief
that there were three gods so you would
knock on the wooden tree and either to
communicate or to wake up that God so
again it goes back to paganism not like
taking out the number thirteen and some
elevators you see right people not
flying under Friday the 13th right what
about this because well the Last Supper
there were twelve men yeah and the
thirteenth man betrayed Jesus yeah so
the thirteen became unlucky yeah and
this happened on the Friday you know if
it's Friday and the 13th oh yeah it's a
very but it's again there's no there's
no science behind it there's no logic
behind it no is there really anything
religious behind it so cutting your
nails on a certain day that's forbidden
or breaking a mirror and not or walking
under a ladder or oh the black cat
you know the black cat across your way
these will all go against whole heat
it's all I mean and not only that's just
nonsensical like the black cat they're
believed to be pets a witch's pet so
which always had a black cat as a pet
but we don't even believe in the witch
obviously the mirror breaking there was
some cultures believe that your
reflection in the mirror was your soul
so the mayor broke something bad would
happen to you so nonsense leave it alone
absolutely okay now hold on to your
seats I mean we have to speak the truth
and we're not trying to be harsh into
people but we're trying to deliver
everything and these were the warnings
and we'll get to the glad tidings but
there was a warning if you die on this
setting up a partner with the one who
created you was the consequence it is
the worst sin ever Allah subhana allah
says in the
and in such a pro number for certain
Mesa allows with it says in La Jolla
Africa be well firma do Nadal economy
Nisha woman you sure could be logical if
Tara Eastman edema Allah does not
forgive that you set up partners with
him but he may forgive anything else to
whomever he wills he could forgive
anything else they won't forgive this
that you set up partners with him and
whoever sets up partners along with
Allah or instead of Allah he has come
forth with something extremely evil
anything clients a lot yeah so so this
is a sin that will never be forgiven
meaning that you need to if you if you
die committing shirk meaning worshiping
something with Allah or besides Allah
you will never go into paradise for all
eternity you will never go into private
but if you're doing it now you repent
stop it then it's like you started over
again so anyone who worship any God you
believe in three gods instead of one or
you or you put any act of worship
Trinity Trinity or any worship towards
anything besides the One God then you
can repent from it this moment he's the
most loving the most merciful God he
will forgive you and you have to go and
like we were saying you don't have to go
anywhere you can get your forgiveness
right now you can repent from it you
don't have to go through anybody just
direct dial up that's it that's it you
just repent God alone Allah alone that's
it and this is again the message you'll
find everywhere you'll find the Oh
throughout the Quran you find it all
throughout Bible Old and New Testament
because it's the biggest sin so the
biggest sin will be worn from the most
yeah and that's the sin actually the in
the Quran that Allah warns us of the
most he one is from lying from you
everything but number one he always
warns people from worshipping something
to say now some people are non Muslim
brothers in humanity now they never
heard this word Allah we know that this
is the the God who created the Sun and
the moon jesus prayed to him Muhammad
prayed to him this is the crater of the
heavens on earth but he never heard it
so they might feel a little bit you know
timid about this what can they do if
they feel this well they just need to
understand it it's just the way you say
God in Arabic yeah we say Allah and
there is actually English versions of
the Bible the hard to find anymore but
the Scofield version of the Bible had
Allah in it it said Allah yeah as as the
name of God yeah so
there you go yeah until they do some
research can they say the Creator who
created who gave me these eyes the one
who gave you my heart the one I've so
Jesus prayed to forgive me guide me I
only want to worship you can I do that
absolutely they can do that yeah that's
simple yeah and this is the most this is
the most important message of Islam so
if you found this message of one God
appealing then that's the most important
thing about it's not everything will
fall in place after that give them the
glad tidings give the glad tidings that
if they die not associating partners in
doing what God wants them to do what's
the ultimate rewards if they die only
believing in one God only worshiping in
one God if you do that then the reward
is eternal paradise eternal power
there's never coming out of it and even
if someone has tons and tons of sins
that cause them to go into the Hellfire
rasoolum explained to us that eventually
they will come out of the Hellfire yeah
why because of late I had a lot there is
no God worthy of worship except Allah
that will bring people out of it that
makes so much sense what about the last
and final message sent to mankind how
should they go about this again
something new you know they have to look
into it talk about just some advice
basically the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah
said lamb was a final Messenger of Allah
he was sent to Arabia fourteen hundred
years ago but the most important thing
the message that he came with which is
the Quran you read the Quran you see the
message of that he came with and you
look at his life and his teachings and
you see that he came with the message
consistent with the message of all the
prophets that came before him so it's
not a diversion from the consistent
message but it's actually a continuation
in a sense and of course we're in the
day and age where you can look that up
and find some good and genuine
information and go to the beam show and
find some other side Sula so the first
thing is to acknowledge which in your
very nature and then from there you got
you need a blueprint how to live your
life do something well that's where the
messengers came last fundamental part
Muhammad peace be upon him that's what
we need to do to be successful thank you
very very much for being with me Allah
the Creator have in the earth reward you
for loving ya
and that is it for another episode of
the Deen show come back every week the
Deen show calm if you want to learn more
or if you're ready to accept the way of
life of all the messengers of God you
want to gain peace call the number on
the screen 1 800 662 Islam
visit our blog section 2 in
act with us and some of our podcasts are
there and this is simple is rational is
logical worship God alone do not set up
a co-equal or Copart nur with God submit
to the one who created you who give you
the eyes the ears the heart everything
that you have you owe it all to him
turn to be thankful to him we'll see you
next time you had an angel Salam alaikum
peace be unto you